Writing code in an Internet
browser is fine, but
you're probably wondering what kind of
tools professional developers use and
how you get something like
this actually onto your phone.
This installation comes in two parts.
First, we're going to install something
called the Java Development Kit and
only once we're done with that,
then will we install Android Studio.
I want you to think of
Android Studio like a workshop.
And this is a pretty special workshop
because it's specifically designed for
making Android applications.
One where we have automated help
that makes creating apps easier.
The thing is, that while this workshop
is great, it's pretty useless without
tools and that's where
the Java Development Kit comes in.
Before we set anything else up, first
we'll install the Java Development Kit.
Essentially we're grabbing our tools.
Then we set up our app making workshop
by installing Android Studio.
Now it's important that you
do these steps in order and
complete them correctly.
If you don't have your tools ready then
you won't be able to do anything in
your workshop.
The whole process of setting both of
these up, should take you about 30
minutes to an hour if your
Internet connection is fast.
Okay, let's get started.